hello there ladies and gentlemen my name
is all Alba I guess we gotta do British
accent name is James James
the name is James see my name has too
many syllables to sound cool John
Humphrey Humphrey like you you've lost
yourself already like you might as well
have an ascot on
we're gonna watch gadgets from the James
Bond series the smooth YouTube channel
elite facts
Elita battle angels facts it's also a
topper war two requests from Mikhail
Linden who oh I saw that would be go
fund me that my girlfriend started up or
one of our very ill cats you contributed
to it so thank you McHale your real
sweetheart thank you are sweetie pie
I owe you a blowy gadgets from the James
Bond series whoa
license to kill Felix is lighter
although not directly intended as a
gadget to be used in the field this
slider was only intended as a party
favor to people who attended CIA agent
Felix sliders wedding the one James Bond
receives at the start of the film is
faulty as when it is lit up the flame
that comes out of the lighter is almost
flamethrower light towards the climax of
the film bonk fights the film's main
antagonist Sanchez next to the wreckage
of a gasoline tanker in what seems to be
a losing battle
lucky for bond he notices that Sanchez
is covered in gasoline when seeing this
he quickly uses the lighter to set
Sanchez on fire some of the more simple
gadgets can prove to be the most useful
in desperate situations like a hen
Skyfall a palm print from Rhode Island
although the Craig era of Bond films has
been more focused on espionage rather
than gadgets and equipment yeah but the
high life all presents us with one of
the more useful gadgets in the bond
series Q presents bond with a while
okay that has a palm scanner built-in
meaning that only bond is able to
operate the gun this is incredibly
useful in cases gun falls into the wrong
hands
Tomorrow Never Dies remote control
remote control BMW the official vehicle
of the film is a BMW 750il which in all
honesty isn't much to look at however it
comes with a really useful gadget in the
form of a remote control device in the
car has a bunch of adapting to the
device as he is controlling the car this
little chasing is incredibly enjoyable
all thanks to this gadget goldeneye
explosive ballpoint pen another gadget
that proves to be simple but effective
the explosive ballpoint pen and
goldeneye is Alec Trevelyan downfall as
his lead programmer Boris tries to
override a password set that is
preventing Alex's plan from coming to
fruition while doing this Boris is doing
this weird pen flip trick that helps him
focus whenever he's working it
unfortunately for him and everyone else
involved with the Goldeneye project this
is the explosive pen that Bond was given
at the start of his mission and Boris
eccentric triggers it to explode causing
the whole inspiration to become a
complete failure I am invincible
patting lights and Whitaker's war room
although it's from a film in the series
that people tend to forget about Brad
Whitaker's warm room is one of the rare
villain gadgets that nearly killed him
near the climax of the film this gadget
rigs up all the miniature displays in
the room that includes guns and cannons
to a remote device when activated it
fires live ammo at whatever the remote
device is pointed at unfortunately for
Whitaker bond is able to use one of his
remote explosives in the form of a
keyring and stealthily place it on a
statue behind Whitaker and set it off so
that the statue would crush it if bond
did not his statute it would be safe to
say that bond would have lost this
shootout
he's always a man with the Golden Gun
the Golden Gun although they're stupid
- well received it did provide us with a
memorable villain Francisco Scaramanga
played by Christopher Lee as well as a
memorable gadget in the form of the
Golden Gun this gun is made up of
everyday items that most people would
find is also greater than cigarette one
shot of a film intent the gun can only
hold a capacity of one bullet before
having to be reloaded however one bullet
is all Scaramanga needs the spine loves
me lotus esprit submarine ah it should
be obvious it's a Lotus Esprit that
functions as a submarine what's not to
like in the spine company there's a
scene in which bond and KGB agent xxx
are being chased down by one of Karl
Stromberg engine helicopter cute as a
way to lose our missiles straight up out
of the water destroying the helicopter
that the henchmen were piloting next to
the Aston Martin db5 this car is iconic
From Russia With Love Russia the
criminal organization known as Spectre
at the start of From Russia With Love
we're shown that red grant is more than
efficient with this gadget as he was
swiftly able to dispose of a tester bond
however the gadget can easily be turned
to go then comments a tester I was able
to use the watch to take out red grant
during the film's climax on the Orient
Express
Skyfall pens light bulb bombs this
gadget is on the list because of how
practical and
when this rigged up bomb I remember this
at all switched on it explodes having a
small fire off in the room as well as I
saw this twice and I don't know what I'm
talking about this yet the clip
Goldfinger asking Martin db5 if you
think James Bond you have to think of
what car he's driving although over the
years he's constantly upgrading to more
modern incarnations of the vehicle the
Aston Martin db5 is known as the truth
bond car this is due to its classy but
sport like looks along with some of the
memorable gadgets that come along with
it this includes a rear bumper oil slick
rear window bullet shield and of course
the ejector seat which makes that
glorious comeback and what is arguably
the worst Bond film to date die another
day as part of the Aston Martin v12
vanquish chase scene this scene alone
almost saved the entire film without
creative it was thanks for watching
another amazing videos subscribe for
more from the leaked bags
let's subscribe no more videos yeah and
if you subscribe we can stop this yeah I
got a thing to say die another day is
often hailed as one of the possibly the
worst Bond movie no no no no no I
another day is terrible I'll give you
that
it is awful it's in comprehendible as I
work incomprehensible huh
although in comprehendible I might be I
was incomprehensible but it's not boring
nothing is worse than boring like
Quantum of Solace that is the worst Bond
movie I'd watch die another day any day
I would die another day to avoid quantum
salt I would let you live in that myself
die if it not having to watch Quantum
see the Quantum of Solace reaches a
special pitch where it's like
hyperkinetic and it's boring fascinating
to me but anyway this list I love that
tomorrow never dies chase sequence in
the parking lot I'm glad they got that
freeze-frame because that is the moment
that's right when the tires come up yes
further flattening you should see this
look eight that with my old gameboy or
you know my dad's phone or something the
Golden Gun one is pretty interesting to
me because that movie is not considered
a good movie mmm yeah the villain and
Christopher Lee is an iconic iconic and
to a certain like Bond legacy but the
Golden Gun is super iconic you know like
the one bullet all it takes
made its way into Goldeneye shame always
wanted that gun I argue that the
Goldeneye game made the Golden Gun more
iconic the probably the movie Holden I
game is one of the most iconic pieces
you know past a certain generation of
the bond anything breaking great for
anyone probably interested in this video
you chances are you play Goldeneye
this video is like bringing up all the
gadgets upon the decades that bond has
been around
and we are coming to a conclusion with a
Daniel Craig Bond franchise there's a
lot of speculation happening right now
where is bond going to end with Daniel
Craig will they kill him cause they vote
he's gonna get killed by a gadget comes
to life and there's a I oh it's the
perfect time to introduce AI into bond
as well and then it will kill him as
he's saving the world yes a human
villain the one gadget they didn't bring
up was his penis it's the greatest
gadget of them all and wonders yeah yeah
I mean it's used in every single one of
the film sometimes overly aggressive
yeah most times I would already too many
situations we're almost at the
conclusion of gang of Craig his bond and
he's barely used any gadgets I think
he's brought up one time here right yeah
I mean while the yeah the the palm
identifier thing on his is with the
ending light bulb thingies yeah like
what oh I must go back a clearly Adele
remember they guest impression I
remember the palm thing I feel like
that's Orson I should have had that
forever I feel like every gun owner that
makes a really easy unless you skinned
somebody's hand and make a glove out of
it which I'm sure so long I mean he had
the car in Casino Royale that like you
know had a defibrillator in it which was
kind of a gadget right what I'm hoping
that this last Bond movie with Daniel
Craig does is it's just an overabundance
of gadgets just went to EKGs thrown in
here I want this climax the movie to
take place in a satellite dish at the
edge of the dradis fear as the moon
starts falling to earth or some [ __ ]
like right that's what I once got to
have it didn't bring up here is watch
his laser yeah which is one of the
coolest things you gets using the game
now I'm not even sure visit a movie out
of
cuts himself off of like a metal gurney
with it or something right sounds like
something in my mind I thought you know
part of what the Craig series wanted to
try and do is like dovetail are like
originated some of the classics he got
the in classic car back at the end of
Specter so let's get him a bunch of
gadgets yeah and this new bunch of yeah
he hasn't had like a gadget motorcycle a
gadget motorcycle would be great why
that you can still do like cool stunts
with it plus you could bring back BMW
you have your Aston Martin car product
placement BMW stands for broke my wallet
oh snap cuz you're always gonna be
fixing that thing yeah yeah and it's
hard it's expensive most BMW owners or
because of bond mm-hmm that's it not
Chris Pines voice on the radio
technology that fits your world while
that too
you know just like never mind they're
not gonna get W covers you know what I'm
very surprised did not make it in here
is nothing from the movie Moonraker
which of all the Bond film seems like it
would be the most rife with crazy
gadgets well I I guess this this list
was a mixture of what came in the best
of handy for certain moments like
started off with something as simple as
a lighter gun then also to what is the
most iconic one and I think Moonraker
it's just probably the big profit
conclusion because the the one and uh
you know like Die Another Day has a
bunch of crazy gadgets too but we don't
know anything about that what what are
your favorite Bond gadgets people yeah
close below tell us what's going on in
your life well guys if you can do this a
solid and subscribe to elite facts that
would be great
they seem to be an amazing Channel
hittin that like any like button you
guys can subscribe the real rejects and
hey you know what while you're at it
click that notification Bell also shouts
out to McHale for requesting this buddy
he's a huge huge bond fan he is always
talking to me about James Bond and
Jessica sure
yeah there's a crossover that needs to
have I don't know why those are the only
two things he likes to talk about but
hey I will feed whatever conversation
you're hoping to engage in me on like I
said thank you again for helping out
with that GoFundMe I know you got more
money so I'm starting out another
GoFundMe separate from the one my
girlfriend started this is just gonna be
for me to go out on the weekends and
have some fun so we want to be really
transparent about what ya donate to my
money chaotic cat whatever yeah it
probably needs more money than what we
got whatever but I like to take breaks
so yeah keep a lookout for that and you
had to read the first one
but don't unplug too cuz I'm making
dinner tonight and I have a GoFundMe
account and you know it's only like 26
bucks probably angry CEO I mean this is
gonna be a really easy goal to hit
people keep a lookout there's a lot of
fun things taco is